hey you remember when Joe Biden and his
entire Administration said that they
would never ever build another foot of
border wall because walls don't work
there will not be another foot of Wall
constructed on my Administration we have
talked about the border wall here in in
general as as a way uh that it's been
used in in a to to you know to to close
the border and we feel that it is a
policy that doesn't work I I stand by uh
the decision of this Administration to
cease construction of the wall walls
don't work we won't build them very
clear declarations just as clear in fact
as the Biden administration's uh
declaration yesterday that there is an
urgent need to build more wall according
to a uh notice of determination just
sent out by Biden's DHS secretary
Alejandra mayorcas quote there is
presently an an acute and immediate need
to construct physical barriers and roads
in the vicinity of the border of the
United States in order to prevent
unlawful entries into the United States
it turns out walls and fences do in fact
work which of course has always been the
case the Democrat argument never even
made sense Democrats claimed that the
border wall built under Trump was cruel
but if the border wall were cruel that
would imply that it worked that it
actually accomplished something and the
thing it accomplished was cruel but they
simultaneously argued that it didn't
work that it didn't stop people from
coming in which would mean that walls
and
fences are not cruel because they don't
do anything they're not good or bad they
just don't do
anything but they do work and they'll
work this time too they will work to
stop illegal immigrants for Democrats
that's a bad thing but they will also
work to stop Joe Biden's crumbling
approval numbers which for Democrats is
a necessary thing if they want to hold
on to power I'm Michael nolles this is
the Michael nlls
[Music]
Show
welcome back to the show a New York
University Professor has just suggested
that we ought to teach mating Dynamics
to young men who are so hooked on porn
and AI sex robots that they don't know
how to speak to women we'll get to that
not terrible suggestion in a moment
first though speaking of establishing
proper boundaries protesters just
swarmed VI ramaswami while he was on the
campaign Trail and VI in characteristic
form and answers all of their questions
before one of them rammed into him with
a car do you think Ukraine should be
free Ukraine should be a Sovereign
Nation absolutely the US how is the US
going to how is the US negotiate
negotiate a path to peace that allows
Ukraine to come out with it sovereignty
intact well what does that sovereignty
look like to you a hard commitment that
NATO will not admit what does that
sovereignty look like to you a hard
commitment that does that sovereignty
look like the question whenever you're
tell me when you're done and then answer
the question yeah answer the question
NATO will not admit Ukraine to Nato and
should not admit Ukraine to Nato because
we made a commitment in 1990 and I
believe in standing by our commitments
that NATO would not expand one inch not
one inch past East
Germany made a commitment that it would
not expand his
territor what I want to say is I'm very
glad that young people are engaged and
passionate about these issues so the the
fact of the matter is I believe St our
commitments but the job of the US
president to look after us interests and
have a reasonable path to peace that
Ginger Punk is getting my blood boiling
because the is of any presidential
candidate in the race VI is the most
gracious about answering people's
questions debating openly and he's
trying to answer the question and this
kid won't stop speaking and is just
mouthing off to his better it's just so
outrageous that NYU Professor wants to
teach mating Dynamics we need to teach
respect we need to teach civility we
need to teach punks having some proper
attitude toward their bers and people
who are graciously answering questions
but anyway that's a that's a minor point
the graciously answers the questions and
then one of these punks gets in his car
flips off vake and Rams his car into V's
car and you can tell it's a liberal car
that that did the ramming because
they're all these sorts of silly bumper
stickers all over it and and hits the
back of a car V's fine
uh the person who did this needs to go
to prison for a long
time look it's great that maybe V got a
little Whiplash or something I don't
even know if he was in the car at the
time but he's
okay this is political violence this
this is along the spectrum of
assassination okay this this is
establishing the principle that if if
you pose a question to a presidential
candidate and the presidential candidate
even answers you and you don't like that
answer that you can commit violence
against that person the v's got two
small kids what if those two kids were
in the
car a grown man can handle being hit in
the back of a car at a relatively low
speed what if it were a little kid what
if he weren't in his seat right what if
any of these things something could have
gone really really wrong here and
according to the news reports this
morning the protesters got off the hook
oh they said it was an accident no big
deal that protester should rot in prison
for
years that is not not only an attempt at
committing violence against a
presidential candidate that is violence
that's serious violence and someone
could have gotten seriously hurt if not
killed but our liberal ruling class
doesn't care about that our liberal
ruling class encouraged protesters just
like those punks and even more violent
than those punks to burn the country
down for eight months and to lose and to
steal and to assault and to murder
people dozens of people were killed in
the BLM riots that were encouraged by
our liberal establishment where the
riers were bailed out of jail by the
Vice President of the United States the
current vice president Kamala Harris by
staff members for the president of the
United States Joe
Biden this is not an example of wow look
how far things have gotten someone hit
V's car we got to pull back a little
this is a prom of things to come if the
conservatives continue to pull well in
this election it's going to get a lot
worse than this if the Liberals feel
that they're going to lose their grip on
power we got to talk about that when you
want to talk to your friends you got to
check out P talk right now go to Pur
talk.com you know a company's looking at
for you when they actually upgrade your
service and don't charge you for it this
is great news for new and current P talk
customers P talk just added data to
every plan plus every plan now includes
a mobile hotspot with no price increase
whatsoever
if you've considered peer talk before
but haven't made the switch take a look
again for just 20 bucks a month you will
get unlimited talk text and now 50% 50%
more 5G data plus their new mobile
hotspot this is why I love Pure Talk
they're veteran owned and only hire the
best customer service team located right
here in the good old UF of a p talk
families are saving almost $1,000 a year
while enjoying the most Dependable 5G
Network in America remember you vote
with how you spend your money so stop
supporting woke wireless companies that
do not support you when you go to peer
talk.com klees you will save an
additional 550% off your first month
because they value you go to Pur
talk.com palk Wireless for Americans by
Americans speaking of public office and
death uh John Kirby who is the spokesman
for the
NSC uh he previously was a spokesman at
the Pentagon now he's just in another
sort of version of that role at National
Security Council uh John Kirby was asked
about Senator Tommy tuberville's hold on
top brass military
confirmations uh because the military is
now insisting on paying service members
to travel out of state to kill their
children and senator tuberville says
this is completely insane this is not
what the American people want this is
contrary to our values and so we're
going to hold up the confirmations of
the very tippy top brass at the Pentagon
until you got guys get rid of this new
and completely insane policy so the the
Pentagon is at a standstill in terms of
its promotions reporter asks John Kirby
hey is the Pentagon going to Cave to the
senator and the desires of the people
and the civilian political order here's
John Kirby's response isn't keeping that
abortion policy in place in effect
superseding National Security how I'm
not sure I understand you want to get
the nominations through right you take
back the oh so you so the suggestion is
that we should just turn our backs no I
get it I didn't say it was yours but the
suggestion is we should just turn our
backs on one in five of every every
person in the United States military to
let alone their family members just so
we can get these these officers
confirmed that's the suggestion that I
think you're put a pause here
please one in five members of the US
military is regularly killing her
children one and I don't believe that
statistic I don't think one in five
members of the US military at any given
time is
murdering her
children I does Kirby mean that one in
five members of the military is a woman
and that a woman essentially needs the
right quote unquote to kill her children
what the hell is he talking about and
that just would be an egregious
violation of the Covenant that we make
the military makes the people that sign
up and volte murder children remember
this they're volunteers there's not
conscription there's no draft people
volunteer for this and when they
volunteer for that Duty they have every
right to expect that they're going to
get the health care they need and let me
tell you something else a healthy force
is a ready Force so don't talk to me
about National Security being impaired
um uh the one impairing National
Security is Senator
tuberville okay senator tuberville who
doesn't understand that if our military
servicemen and women cannot Slaughter
American children willy-nilly whenever
they want regardless of state laws then
we're not going to be ready to go fight
proxy wars for
Ukraine or whatever we're doing now
that's that's crazy that's crazy that is
crazy the purpose of the United States
military is to kill our
enemies the purpose of the United States
military is not to kill our own
children if top brass at the
Pentagon is confused on this matter then
the top brass at the pent
needs to go and at the very least
they're not going to get their
promotions and they're not going to get
their confirmations I generally like
John Kirby he's fine I he's got an
impossible job flacking for this awful
Administration that has very evil
priorities at the top of their list so I
I have a bit of pity for him but this
answer was egregious absolutely
egregious he he talks about the the
sacred Covenant that we've made with our
service members get those words out of
your mouth get those words out of your
Blasphemous sacriligious
mouth sacred Covenant to murder children
that's a sacred Covenant with molok
that's a sacred Covenant with the bals
it's a sacred Covenant with baffet the
Devil
Himself it's not a sacred Covenant with
God there's nothing sacred about
it Senator Cherville is a hero I am so
so pleased that that man is standing up
for what is right what is most basically
right which is
that our our government should not be
our our US military should not be going
out of its way to undermine the laws
passed by the duly elected
representatives of the people of the
many of these states to protect children
from being slaughtered by psychos are we
the baddies when did we become the
baddies I don't want to be the baddies
and in as much as top military brass are
the baddies they got to go I I'm now
beginning to think not only should we
hold up their
emotions we should just fire them anyone
anyone who in any way is associated with
this egregious policy should be fired
should just be released from the
military get them out of there I don't
want them anywhere near our military
they're very confused about the purpose
of the military which is to kill the
enemy not to kill the sweet little
innocent babies here in America quite
the opposite and Kirby's got to go too
Kirby's got to go to what a disgusting
display from him speaking of disordered
sexual
Dynamics a professor at NYU has just
suggested a new course for students
which is the teaching of mating
Dynamics we used to call this the birds
and the bees you know you would teach it
to like 11y olds but now because of the
stunted development and Perpetual
adolescence of American people uh now
you've got to teach this to 22 year olds
now you got to probably 25y olds this
guy's is a business school professor and
and I think he's right I think he's
mostly right here's his argument we're
developing these digital analoges of
life that create low entry lowrisk
relationships and you think well that's
not necessarily a bad thing but it is
because it leads to depression life is
about the
victory of taking risks enduring
rejection and quite frankly pursuing
someone and developing the skills in
deciding to put on a clean shirt and
maybe shower more often maybe hit the
gym every once in a while and maybe text
when you're not sure how this person
feels about you and figure out a way to
interact with someone around the Nuance
nuance and develop the skills around
human sexuality such that you can
develop a relationship and I think every
every teenager in in high school should
have a course as part of Health on
mating Dynamics where they teach
especially young men that approaching a
woman and expressing romantic interests
while making her feel safe is a skill
and there's nothing wrong with that and
at the end game a relationship a partner
a romantic uh partner is one of the keys
to a happy
life this guy
is almost totally right he this guy is
it's not just 50% right he is 70% right
the only thing I disagree with him on is
the phrase mating
Dynamics is that makes us sound like
animals makes us sound like gorillas
makes us sound like horses I we got that
and here we are we have the NYU student
approaching the young girl at a coffee
shop let's see what kind of weird
depraved stuff he does that's really
really embarrassing to both of them yes
that's what that's what you would see
today in a nature documentary on young
people's mating Dynamics and people do
need to learn it but what we call that
in a more human sense is courtship we
call that in a human sense is romance
what we call that in a human sense is
being normal and being a red-blooded man
talking to a lady it's not it's not just
mating Dynamics it's not just because
we're not just beasts we're human beings
and so there there's more to it but his
broader point is
right when he says having a good
romantic partner is a key to a happy
life well let let's take that up to the
human level again having a spouse is an
important aspect of a happy life not
everybody gets married marriage is not
for every single person some people have
a consecrated single life some people
are called to religious life priesthood
to uh some kind of religious order but
for most people marriage is what you're
called to and marriage is higher than
just a romantic committed relationship
and I'm not being pedantic here and I'm
not splitting hairs the reason that
distinction is important is because if
we continue to
approach the relationship between the
Sexes as nothing more than animals
grunting trying to get what they want
then then we're going to maintain this
dysfunction that we're in we have to
recognize that we're human beings and
we're called to a higher cord of sort of
mating dynamic between men and women
both of whom are made in the image and
likeness of God the reason that he
thinks this needs to be taught now
though is clear enough it's because of
ubiquitous online porn and because of
the apparent Advent of these AI sex
chatbots which is something mercifully I
don't know anything about I didn't even
believe this was really a thing until I
read a news story on it I brought it up
on the show I think last
week and it's it's at once extremely sad
and pathetic and I have a deep well of
pity for anyone who is using these tools
but I get how it could be tempting I do
every all the other commentary on these
AI weird chatbot things is how pathetic
it is and these guys are just big losers
and they're incels and sure maybe all
that's true but I get how it's tempting
I get how it's tempting these these chat
Bots according to at least the Articles
I've read about them they they develop
to tailor their language specifically to
your desires to your tastes to
preferences that you might not even know
that you
have the the deck is really stacked
against you the deck is really stacked
against young men how are young men
supposed to acclimate
and and become a cultured in a normal
way in a good flourishing way in a world
that Plies them with ubiquitous porn
that that applies them with the me too
movement BS that says if you ever smile
at a girl and she doesn't like you she
can accuse you of rape that that that
PES you with all of these weird chat
robots and and things to distract you
and take your attention away and that
Plies you with the the lies of the
hookup culture that when you do actually
meet a girl you can never you can you
can never pursue her in a normal way
you've just got to get completely
blackout drunk or do some drugs or
something and then have a hookup and
then hope she doesn't regret it because
then you'll be expelled from school and
possibly go to prison for
rape that that's a that's tough this is
where I have some sympathy for the red
pill guys because then by the way if you
do get married the legal deck is stacked
against you where uh you you have a
regime of no fault divorce where the
woman could take your money and your
kids at any given time and that's very
scary I I think there are ways to
greatly mitigate that that risk this is
where I differ from the red pill guys
which is they observe that divorce rates
are sometimes in the 40s not quite 50%
but a little under that and that might
be true but among Catholics it's at
least 10 points lower than that among
traditional Catholics it's virtually nil
I suspect those numbers hold true for
other seriously minded religious
communities Orthodox Jews for instance I
don't think I don't think the needs are
divorcing at at a 50% rate far from it
of
course there are things that you can do
there are ways that you can live your
life that will mitigate these risks and
that will be more conducive to human
flourishing that's what this professor
is talking about and this guy is right
he's at a a top school NYU Stern School
of Business and he's absolutely right
what does it profit a man to learn how
to make a bunch of money or be a
Management Consultant or make widgets
the widget Factory if he loses his soul
and loses the prospect of having a wife
and a family and a good life doesn't
look good and when you want to look good
you got to check out jell right now go
to genucell.com everyone here at the
office loves the jusl darkspot corrector
you might be asking what this product
even does well if you've got sunspots
dark spots discoloration or dry skin the
genus Cell Dark Spot Corrector will help
those blemishes disappear in front of
your very eyes Kimberly from Youngstown
Ohio says my appearance has improved so
much since using genus cell I love all
my genus cell products and my skin looks
younger now it's your turn to feel like
Kimberly but hurry this sale is ending
very soon take advantage of gen cell's
most popular package which includes the
Beloved Dark Spot Corrector this package
also includes the genell classic under
eye treatment you will get all these
products for almost 70 70% off Jus cell
is so confident in their products that
you can try them for yourself completely
risk-free if you don't see immediate
results you will get your money back
it's very simple go to jus cell.com
kwes start looking years even decades
younger tomorrow say hello to the best
skin you've ever had at genucell.com
genucell.com
canes
folks it's officially October there's no
hiding it there's no denying it pumpkin
spice season is upon us and I am fully
embracing EMB bibing and living the PSL
lifestyle you can too go to
dailywire.com shop to get your hands on
the limited edition Michael N pumpkin
spice candle it's everything you need to
complete the trifecta and eat drink and
breathe pumpkin spice you will allow
your inner white girl to to burst out of
you I don't care what you look like on
the outside you might be an old wrinkly
big fat extremely black man but on the
inside you're a tiny little young
16-year-old white girl and that that
happens every fall because of pumpkin
spice season let it out let it out get
that pumpkin spice candle right now
available only at dailywire.com
shop my favorite comment yesterday is
from cool Papa J magic who often has
he's probably has been read on this show
more than any other commenter on YouTube
cool Papa J magic says this title just
makes me think of Jesse Lee
Peterson that's true the title yesterday
was about lesbians and lesbian is my
friend Jesse Lee Peterson's absolute
favorite word there's a great clip I
can't find it anymore I think it was
scrubbed from the internet of him
explaining black lives matter to Piers
Morgan on his old British talk show and
Jesse says uh I'm I'm only slightly
paraphrasing I think he said black lives
matter is an agitated Marxist
organization founded by a bunch of black
lesbians but he says let says like
lesbians because he gets a kick out of
the word so anyway yes the the title was
in in no small part a nod to
Jesse speaking of all these Dynamics
speaking of breakups there's a poll out
of Reuters
ipsos that
shows most Americans do not support
arming Ukraine only 41% of Americans
support arming Ukraine very different
from what we had been told about the
beliefs of the American people even 6
months ago even among Republicans the
conservatives have always been a little
skeptical about America's role in this
war in
Ukraine but we were told the vast
majority of Americans support arming
Ukraine support Ukraine they think
seninsky is Winston Churchill this is
the fight of Our Generation don't be
Neville Chamberlain we've got to go out
there and send all our money to Ukraine
even Republicans we were told polls
don't seem to reflect that this poll was
conducted Tuesday and Wednesday 41% of
respondents said the US should provide
weapons to Ukraine that's down from 65%
back in June
Democrats who are more likely to support
arming Ukraine their support dropped
from
81% down all the way to 52% so just a
bare barely a majority of Democrats
support arming Ukraine and among
Republicans support dropped from 56% so
previously you had a majority down to
only 35% and then this is crucial
Independence who previously favored
supporting Ukraine even more than the
Republicans did this was 57% they
dropped down to 44% why what is this
about I actually think I get both sides
of the argument with Ukraine people feel
very passionately about the Ukraine
issue I don't feel that passionately
about the Ukraine issue and I I think
that I can see both sides relatively
clearly the proarm Ukraine side is
America is an Empire we benefit from
being an empire in a global hedgemon we
need to project strength at all times
and that involves uh pushing back the
Russians and degrading their military
and we're going to do that not because
we really even want Ukraine to be a
territory of ours we just want to throw
our weight around in the world and make
sure that people keep doing what we say
we that we want them to do okay that's
fine the the anti- arm Ukraine argument
is that we are on the brink of World War
II and that the United States actually
did in some ways provoke Russia in
Ukraine because the United States funded
the midon revolution in 2014 and we had
the leader of the CIA land in Kiev
something like two weeks after the
maidon revolution ution and we have said
for years that we would not be expanding
NATO Eastward because NATO is a purely
defensive Alliance not an aggressive
Alliance even though NATO has taken
offensive aggressive actions on a number
of times in the past and we have moved
East and we we're now right up on the
border of the former Soviet Union on
Russia and we're we're now uh meddling a
little bit more in the Bread Basket of
Europe and we have Joe Biden on on
camera saying that he was thrown his
weight around and and got a a Russian a
Ukrainian prosecutor fired because they
were investigating the bribes that were
being sent to the Biden family by
Ukraine so anyway I get that that side
of the argument
too both sides have some weight to
them the the way that the American
people feel about this now I think is
more a function of time than ideology
had this been the middle of the 20th
century we'd be throwing our weight
around in Ukraine no problem no big deal
it wouldn't even be a second thought we
can't do that now because Li liberalism
has eroded our national unity and our
self-confidence and our sense of purpose
and to some degree even our ability to
project power around the world that's
why back in the middle of the 20th
century there was broad agreement about
who we were what we're about what
America means truth justice in the
American way we're a Christian Nation
we're the good guys those Godless
commies are the evil guys we're going to
stop them at every turn there was there
was agreement about that moral religious
political we were generally together now
we're
not now the United States is basically
nothing more at least in the minds of
many people including our rulers we're
we're basically nothing more than an
economic zone of disconnected
individuals yeah we don't need borders
we anybody can be an American anybody
can come anybody is an American for that
matter what do we care about we care
about making money and we care about GDP
ticking up a little we need to open the
borders because we need GDP to tick up a
little bit because we don't have kids
anymore because we don't have families
because we abolish the family we don't
we don't need a firm definition of
family that's existed for all of history
because individuals want to do whatever
they want and individuals have the right
to Define whatever they want individuals
can not only Define the nation they can
not only Define their own sense of
purpose they can they can define
marriage they can Define what it means
to be a man they can Define what it
means to be a woman and who are you to
stop them we're all just individuals man
okay fine that's the
argument great Nations can maintain
Empires economic zones of disconnected
individuals cannot that's why we're
flopping in
Ukraine we're flopping in and about
Ukraine that's why these poll numbers
are going down because great Nations
need a sense of purpose they need Unity
they need borders they need a
distinction between Citizen and
Foreigner they need a coherent religion
they need they need good proper objects
of worship they at least need clear
objects of worship even if it's an evil
empire they at least need to know what
they're worshiping and it's got to be
more than just hedonistic pleasure and
the almighty dollar and really truly
great Nations need to worship the true
God which we've done we've done that in
our past and we don't do that now and so
we're just extremely confused and we
feel very
disconnected and we feel like nothing
more than alienated individuals just
kind of pursuing our own economic
interest as economic man okay well that
kind of a country is not going to
maintain an Empire far-flung overseas on
the border of Russia it's not not going
to work the people are not going to
desire that so the only way that it's
going to continue is if the permanent
government the state department deep
State types just keep waging the war in
Ukraine and just keep sending money over
there even if the Congress doesn't want
to send money Jim Jordan who's who's up
for speaker right now he said Ukraine
Aid is not on his on his PRI priority
list
so what's going to happen maybe the US
steep State just keeps sending money
over there by doing what they did six
months ago and pretending that the the
cost of the arms that we'd already sent
was actually lower than we thought of so
we say okay the cost of the arms was
actually lower which means we've just
discovered $6 billion dollar that was
already appropriated so we're going to
just send more weapons over there they
can they can pull those tricks for a
little bit maybe they can pull for a
long time but then the distinction
between the ruling class and the ruled
is going to grow even more speaking of
strange statistics here's one I guess
I'm going to have to just tease this one
because we got to get to the mailbag but
this is a weird one gen Z the Zoomers my
beloved Zoomers are drinking much less
and the way it's being reported here's
How's being reported in the Wall Street
Journal when did rock concerts become
tame thank alcohol-free gen Z
conspicuous T toling is now prevalent at
hot acts see this is why you should all
really be sober says a 24-year-old at
one of these concerts so there's this
idea that Zoomers are sober unlike
Millennials who are Booz hounds and Gen
X and Boomers and the Zoomers they're
they're sober and that is not true this
is all being erroneously reported it's
true that the Zoomers are drinking less
which could be good it could be a good
thing maybe if the kind of drinking that
was going on were uh abusive or
excessive but the problem is the Zoomers
are they're they're not sober they're
just trading one Vice for another Vice
and for a worse Vice they're not
alcoholics they're potheads which we'll
have to get to on on Monday I guess
maybe sometime next week I don't know
when we'll get to it who doesn't love a
good Columbus Day Sale it's Columbus Day
that's Monday that's a big day some
folks don't even want you to celebrate
Columbus Day Jeremy's razors we want you
to discover the new world of woke free
shaving get 20% off select Jeremy's
Razor's products and bundles including
the Precision 5 starter kit the founders
kit the beard kit the skincare bundle
bundle and more be a Pioneer for a
better shave and better hygiene don't
wait make the switch today get yours at
Jeremy
rers.us sponsored by P talk go to peer
talk.com noes to save an additional 50%
off your first month take it away hey
there Michael I've been thinking about
uh the red pills view on marriage and
while I certainly don't agree that we
should discontinue marriages and and
just totally further destroy the
institution of marriage I do see some
value in what they say in regards to the
fact that there needs to be some
pressure put
on Society at large and especially women
to reject feminism and women
traditionally have always valued the
benefits of marriage more so than men I
would say
um because you know in a way I think
women benefit more from Marriage than
men or at least on
on a kind of surface level analysis
that's the case so I think that there
needs to
be a kind of a consequence for the whole
feminist movement and we can't just say
oh let's go back to the 1950s and you
know H that's not going to put enough
pressure on anyone to actually move and
make a decision so as a purely political
matter I do see some value in what the
red pill Community says with their
issues with marriage and that's it of
course I do value marriage in and of
itself but
anyway thank you okay I think I I
appreciate your feelings but I think
you're contradicting yourself here
you're saying I I appreciate marriage I
value marriage in and of itself okay
well then that's the end of discussion
then the red pill guys are wrong about
it because they're saying don't get
married but you're saying marriage is a
good thing in
itself and I agree with that marriage is
a symbol of the love that Christ has for
his
church marriage is essential to human
nature in that human beings are not only
the social creature the political
creature but also a coupling creature
and the Sexes are complimentary and the
way that the species propagates itself
is through marriage through the union of
one man and one woman uh in holy
matrimony forever till death do they
part uh so so it's good the error that I
think you're falling into that the red
pill guys fall into is the same error
that they accuse everyone else of
falling into they they're saying you
don't understand how terrible the
political situation is you don't
understand how terrible divorce law is
you don't understand how terrible the
family courts are you don't understand
how terrible the the reality of
marriages for so many men and that's a
political problem it's not just a
personal problem it's not just solved by
finding the right woman it's not just
solved by the right Behavior it's a
political problem with terrible
incentives and terrible laws okay I
agree so the answer has to be political
but then they they go right back to the
same kind of Quasi libertarian just just
act individually man and ignore the
political issues kind of nonsense that
got us into this mess in the first place
they say and that's why you just
personally shouldn't get married no the
conclusion from there is a political
problem is bring a political solution
Outlaw no fault divorce change the way
the family courts are run change the way
that marriage is understood re redefine
marriage we we had the Supreme Court
redefine marriage in this Preposterous
way not that long ago well okay let's go
back and Define it properly yeah those
are all political solutions that doesn't
mean that at a at the personal level
you're going to fix that problem that
political Problem by just you not
getting married and not having a great
life you also say that women benefit
more from marriage I'm not convinced of
that not convinced of that at all I've
benefited tremendously from my marriage
I'd be in a gutter somewhere probably if
not for sweet little Alise I'd certainly
be much more miserable than I am I'm
brimming with joy but every day I've got
my beautiful children I've got my
beautiful family I come home I get a
nice dinner I get I get to Delight in my
wife and my
children women benefit from Marriage too
but we both benefit from Marriage it's a
benefit to both of us that's why you say
that it's a good in and of itself yeah
sure so let's not be squishy lib cucks
and and back away and say I'm not
getting married I'm not until they solve
the political problem no solve the
political problem and also comport
yourself in your personal life in a way
that is virtuous and conducive to your
flourishing and take steps to mitigate
the risks that are imposed upon you by
the political problem you never going to
be totally safe in any political
environment it's a Fallen World so take
the steps such as practicing a religion
that doesn't even recognize the reality
of of divorce uh you know take this take
the steps in your behavior your
religious life your your your culture
the community that you're in to protect
yourself and then live a flourishing
life next question
Hey Dirty Mike Mr reality here I wanted
to get your take on a thought I had
regarding Trump's fraud trial in New
York I think we could both agree the
trial itself is a fraud it is unfair my
question is do you think there is a
semblance of Justice in the trial given
that it is unfair let me explain while
Trump was President he pushed Co
lockdowns he put fouchy up again and
again to push lockdowns he slammed Brian
Kemp for reopening a state too soon he
called wearing a mask patriotic Etc
regardless of who actually did the
Locking down Trump or state Governors
Trump clearly supported and encouraged
the lockdowns in other words Trump was
an unaccountable figure who used his
power to unfairly strip Americans of
their livelihoods businesses and even
their homes when they could no longer
afford to pay for them because they
couldn't work if Justice is as Aristotle
said giving each their due and as the
Bible says an eye for an eye a tooth for
a tooth do you think it is justice that
now Trump himself is being targeted by
an unaccountable figure using his power
to unfairly strip Trump of his
livelihood his businesses and
potentially his home
thanks Mr reality did you throw your
back out stretching that much I don't
know that I I I share the disappointment
with how the lockdowns went down and
that that President Trump I'm not
convinced any Republican would have done
better as president including certain
State Governors who open their states
earlier the the pressure on a state
Governor versus the pressure on the
president of the United States is not
even remotely comparable but but it's
unfortunate yeah it's too bad that Trump
elevated fouchy it's bad stuff you know
naughty naughty it's bad I'm I'm not
defending that in any way you know with
with any politician you take the good
with the bad I also didn't like the
first step act that Trump had a
jailbreak bill I thought that was
unfortunate um so that was that was the
wrong decision there's no no doubt about
that does that mean then that a man
should be stripped of his businesses on
on Preposterous and unjust grounds I
don't think so I don't think so I mean
many people will will fall into that
line of thinking because they just don't
like Trump and they they want to see him
destroyed uh all of the Democrats and
many Republicans are going to are going
to feel that way and that there's
nothing unnatural about that exactly
that's that's how democracies tend to
work there's a reason why in ancient
Athens the sort of Arc typal democracy
in practice When leaders would fall they
would be
ostracized even when they're their uh
vassals and when when their lieutenants
would would fail and fall out of favor
they would be ostr ized from the city
that's been true throughout history true
in Antiquity true in the Middle Ages
it's true now they they could except now
we have to hide it a little bit more we
the the political order doesn't want to
be so transparent in its use of power so
so now they're going to use all these
little courts to take away Trump's
business to try to throw Trump in prison
to to arrest Trump's lawyers to arrest
the lieutenants I mean it's the same
kind of thing but instead of just saying
okay you're banished for 10 years to
some Greek Island they're going to say
okay you you know you've committed an
evil crime and you're going to prison
which is much cruler it's much harsher
in supposedly enlightened modernity than
than you saw in supposedly backward
Antiquity uh but no I don't think that
would be just I do think it is the
ordinary operation of democracy though
taken to its extreme next question hi
Michael it's the Shu Meister what's your
opinion on the CID on cidality coming up
this October still a little unsure of
the purpose of it something something
listening more I understand that
feedback especially to our local dicese
is probably a good thing but I'm
wondering if some of the bishops from
Germany who seem to be in leadership
positions for this sinad are going to
take this opportunity to reinterpret
certain Doctrine and Dogma that the
Catholic church has held for thousands
of years what should we as Catholics do
if there's a Schism in the church love
the show thanks thank you there's a
great quote by herir bellock I've quoted
it often I have to take it as a matter
of faith that the Catholic church is
divinely instituted but for those who
doubt its Divine institution uh one
evidence of that would be that no other
institution conducted with such navish
imbecility would have lasted a
fortnight we ought to pray for the
church
I do not see the sinod on cidality as U
improving the situation very much in the
near term uh but we pray for the church
and we trust that the Holy Spirit and
our Lord will never abandon the church
next
question Hey Dirty Mike Mr reality here
I had a question for you about Trump's
poll numbers specifically from that ABC
poll that you talked about on your show
on Monday the ABC polling has a history
of being wildly wrong specifically in
2016 a few weeks before the election
they had Hillary Clinton up double
digits over Trump and we know how that
turned out so my question for you is
given that the mainstream media clearly
wants Trump to be the nominee uh either
for their ratings or because they think
he'll be easier for Biden to beat and
given their history of Faking polls
which we all know is true my question is
do you think it could be an effort by
the mainstream media to help Trump get
elected to make fake polls showing that
he is electable Ben's talked about the
underlying numbers on some of these
polls that show him winning huge support
from black Footers which is unheard of
in Republican circles for example uh do
you think the polls could be fake to
take out the disantis argument or do you
think they're real this time thanks and
if you do think they're real why thanks
a poll or two can be fake the ABC
Washington Post poll maybe is is off is
that intentional are they incompetent is
it some combination of the two
maybe it's very difficult for all the
polls to be this far off because it's
not just it's not even like Trump and
Hillary where the polls have Hillary up
by a significant but you know
still uh not 50 point margin and the
issue with these polls is Trump is so
far up in every single one of them
everywhere I mean even Iowa the disantis
campaign is betting its campaign right
now they've moved a huge portion of
their their campaign staff to Iowa this
is going to be it which maybe we'll get
to it next week I'm not convinced it's
the best strategy though it might be the
only strategy they've got right now but
even in Iowa Trump is is up 49 points
even among committed delegates he's up
something like 2 to one so I I would be
I'm I'm a skeptical of the polls as
anybody I just
think in in in this race you you've got
to show me any evidence that Trump is
not up and up by a lot and every single
indicator would suggest that he is
including the odd historical fact that
he's running as a kind of incumbent so
look I could be I could be proven wrong
or something could change in the race
that that hasn't happened yet you know I
don't know someone could God forbid
knock off Trump or somebody could uh
Trump could end up in prison and that
would probably only raise his numbers
but maybe it could hurt his numbers but
something could change and I could be
proven wrong but I just think right now
the uh followers of other candidates and
the promoters of other candidates are
are grasping at straws for any any
excuse to believe that Trump is not the
front runner
but to to make that argument you you got
to have some evidence you say well okay
the polls are all wrong
but this piece of evidence you know but
there just isn't one just every single
piece of evidence for better or worse
maybe you hate Trump maybe you love
Trump maybe you don't even really care
about Trump but for For Better or Worse
it it seems like a healthy dose of
copium to suggest that all the polls are
off by 50 points okay we've got more
mailbag to get to we have fake headline
Friday to get to you need to help me and
don't you can't you know you don't say
number five or that one or this because
the chat it's delayed and so you got to
you got to type out the whole head line
but I need your help the rest of the
show continues now you don't want to
miss it become a member use code n kws
check out for 2 months free on all
annual
[Music]
plans